mr. Tesla Model T 1 which deviates with
international humanitarian realize the
difference and it's Willa imitates
unbalanced and we learned it's a good
opportunity to advance enhanced develop
simple everybody is distant we are in
big step forward at this discussion is
able to gather what's the duration of
the world but probably more time to
achieve divorce remastered and the other
important point is that America believe
this blood relation to American Society
been having some examples of work some
grantees are doing on our green jobs
working in one Powerman and good news
and Latin Americans meaning the
regulation to meet this